uh wasallu
Gus said I know Yoshi said to base jokes
quality off of showcase what about mics
with audiences okay good we're getting
some questions going here so this is our
weekly q a so please do comment with
your questions and we are happy to
answer them and we're going to get into
Yoshi winning no big deal we'll get to
it but maybe we could start
with uh wasallu's question what do you
think he said Yoshi said to base jokes
off quality of showcases but what about
mics with audiences
so I want to be careful about uh that
real quick so I think what I mentioned
is that
if you're at a mic at an open mic and
there's nothing but Comics there that's
a hard barometer to say that your jokes
work in front of real people not that
Comics are not real people but that's a
hard transition to be like or like a
hard uh barometer that your jokes
actually work for real people if there's
only Comics there now if it's a mic that
has an audience that is a good place
because you're actually getting audience
feedback and audience reaction
it's just
Comics are a weird audience to test out
your jokes on
because
they're not necessarily paying attention
to your jokes
in that way and if you're making jokes
for comics
that's not a real audience so always say
your joke quality
is better if you're doing some of your
material at least in front of real
audiences or in front of people that are
paying to see you
um
so I I guess the best way to say this is
if there's a real audience that's the
best place to actually test the
barometer of your jokes
if it's only comedians not that you
shouldn't test any material but just
know
Comics are not a real audience they're a
subset of an audience but they're not a
real audience
so I don't know if I'm just skirting the
issue or not but I hope that helps
clear it up yeah yeah I think yeah that
is the funny thing about doing these
live streams every week is that people
watch and listen and they remember
what we say
matters
um yeah so that's something important to
remember but that is interesting and
this is my point of view is coming from
I would say that
anytime regards to the audience anytime
you're on a stage saying your jokes out
loud they're getting better like at the
end of the day you have to be on stage
so much you have to say these jokes so
many times like I don't even think till
maybe
I don't even want to say a number
because then people will
I mean listen I remember doing an open
mic at like at a bar at like on a Monday
at 11 and I remember seeing Rodney Perry
in there
like and Rodney Perry's been doing
comedy over 20 years
all this amazing things he's done and I
was like dude what are you doing here
and he's like he's like I'm a comic he's
like I'm working you know he's like I'm
working this out now and now this same
Open Mic I saw many cool kids quote come
in here see what the vibe is and then
leave you know what I mean I I firmly
believe that no stage time is bad stage
time especially for the first several
years so here's the thing there's a
difference in stage time
versus the reaction that you're getting
from the audience and using that as the
basis for feedback for your material
right and here's the thing that's that's
such a good point and it's a good
clarification because somebody asked me
about that this weekend at uh in Florida
somebody said uh they mentioned man I
hate going to open mics because there's
just nothing but Comedians and I said
open mics are needed so you get your
jokes out you have to get your jokes out
so as many open mics as possible
comedians are non-comedians in the
audience you have to get used to saying
your jokes into a microphone to people
as often as possible
um I think where it changes is whether
you're going to use that feedback from
the audience to say whether a joke
worked or not that's where it kind of
isn't okay does that make sense yeah
that does make sense and really it like
you some people have different systems
you know some people do a joke five
times oh across five different shows and
see if it's worth keeping some 10 some
do it for a few months and then we'll
just be like okay fine I'll stop doing
it type deal you know but it is a law of
averages that just the more you get on
stage the more feedback you'll get and
the more accurate because each literally
the crazy thing about comedy is
literally each show
is completely like different you can go
to an open mic One Night in front of all
comics and everyone's on their phone and
not really paying attention you could do
the same Open Mic the next week and for
some reason everyone's engaged and
really like giving each other productive
like I've done some open mics where the
comics are literally like there to help
each other and they're like actually
paying attention and trying to make the
stage time more productive like yeah
but yeah to gauge what's worth keeping
or not yeah that's I mean gosh you do
the joke at least 10 times I would say
and then see how it feels and go from
there
for sure yeah yeah at least a couple of
times I think the key is don't abandon a
joke if it's not getting a reaction you
just gotta try it out in front of enough
people yeah that are like okay we've
heard it we've heard the setup we've
heard this punchline and it's really
around whether it's got legs or not
that's why I always say like does it at
least have legs I'll say that's what I
use that's what I like about open mics
with Comics because at least
Comics you know hopefully you have like
a couple of comics that you can kind of
go to that you could be like hey was
that trash or do you really think that
has like legs and I think that's
important to have at least like some
comedy homies that are real with you
about whether a joke has
legs or not whether joke has like enough
for you to like pursue or not pursue and
then you know that's where the audience
thing also comes into play an audience
will definitely let you know amen that
was that's not great
especially if it keeps bombing
um
so yeah I think it is a weird dynamic
when you start figuring out whether
you're going to keep a joke or not keep
a joke but that's why you keep working
it out that's why
you should try different jokes different
ways in different rooms
um you know like try it one way in front
of comics try it a different way in
front of audiences and then switch it
the next time and see what happens
yeah and I've and I say this on like the
the online class about writing but
basically like following your sense of
humor sorry my dog is slightly freaking
out right now because he heard my wife
outside but it's literally like if you
believe if a joke isn't working but you
believe something is there like give it
time like give it a few months if you
really believe that there's something
there keep trying to figure it out keep
trying to find new angles or
perspectives in your writing that you
can then try on stage and keep working
at it and at a certain point if the joke
isn't hitting like you want it to it's
not saying get rid of it but just shelf
it and let it firm it a little bit and
let it mature a little bit and refine
like a wine and then when you come back
to it with fresh eyes you may it may
unlock you know you know there's jokes
that have taken years that I put to the
side and all sudden it comes back and it
connects to this whole other bit that
now becomes a chunk so this is a
marathon at at every step this is a
marathon and something interesting I
just heard
it was um Big Jay oakerson and Tom
Segura talking about Big J just released
a comedy special on how he's starting
over and they were both talking about
how that feeling of like oh no like I've
put all my material out there now I have
nothing and the the fear with that and
they have to go back to the grindstone
of working out jokes trying them out
refining them like even at their level
they're going through those insecurities
they're going through that process of
like what am I going to say what is why
does it does this even gonna work or
whatnot can I even do comedy anymore
like at every level we're all going
through the same thing so just know that
you're not alone in this process and
just just enjoy it
yeah and while Salu said would you
suggest trying out new jokes in the
middle of a showcase set at a comedy
club
I mean
I wouldn't you
yeah yeah yeah yeah because here's the
thing here's here's here's what I say
and the reason I would the reason I
would uh and I think that's that's where
that's where it it just depends on your
like sensibility and your like sort of
how comfortable you are I will try a
joke in front of an audience not even an
audience like in front of a place that I
have performed before if it's like a
brand new place I I will not if it's
like a break but if it's like a place
that I'm comfortable like I'm just
comfortable in certain rooms and it
doesn't matter like the people who are
there because I know it's not the same
audience but there's just some rooms
that I'm like oh I'm comfortable in this
room and yes I will try a new bit a
brand new bit that I have not tried
before in the middle of my set because I
know that I have the audience in terms
of everything else has sort of worked so
it's kind of like
I just want to see if this has like
some level of potential but I'm only
doing that if I'm feeling myself even if
I'm not like
I would say I don't plan on doing that
but if like something inspires me or
like I'm on a roll I'm like oh
I'm I'm good right now I can try
something completely new and even if it
fails and even if it like bombs I know
that I've got the room and I've got the
material to recover in the middle of the
set like and be okay with that so I
don't mind doing that
um now I don't do it often but I've
definitely you know probably the last
couple months I've done that a couple
times but I just had a nice little idea
of just something I was like let me just
see if this will work in the middle of
this
personal preference
cushion it between jokes you know works
I mean there's no no harm no foul yeah
but I was listening I was reading his as
like it's like a showcase
at a comedy club and if you're like a
newer comic they just want to see if you
can kill or not they don't really I mean
honestly like Comedy Club Bookers aren't
like oh they're doing the same jokes and
they're killing oh I don't want to book
them because I know they can kill
consistently and are reliable
like every Booker I've interviewed it's
like we just want you because people
will ask like should I do if I send a
tape to a Booker and they book me should
I do that same material and it's yeah
like every book I've interviewed and me
being a Booker it's like yes yeah you
book yes you're booked because
material yeah yeah so they're booking
you because of that so yeah at the end
of the day it's personal preference yeah
if you wanna if you wanna
throw up a Hail Mary in the middle of
your set just to see if it sticks go for
it if you want to just stay in the
pocket and just play the the greatest
hits go for it it's kind of it's kind of
personal preference at the end of the
day because I've I've followed the rules
of like hang out at the comedy club
follow up with the booker blah blah and
it didn't pan out for me I know other
people who just fell into getting booked
at a comedy club every weekend like yeah
there's literally at the end of the day
it's like just yeah there's no formula
keep getting funny yeah yeah there's a
day I mean I think it's you know uh
somebody mentioned the uh HBO special
with signs oh yeah Jerry did yeah he
called it a program too which really
shows his age
the old HBO program
my favorite thing about it is I remember
a friend of mine
um went to go see Jerry Seinfeld and
they're like man it was the greatest
show and then the next year they were
like oh you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna get
closer and I'm gonna get even better
seats the next year and you know what
Jerry Seinfeld did the same Greatest
Hits they were so upset they were so
upset not realizing that Jerry just has
a philosophy of no no I play The
Greatest Hits I don't care from what
generation it is and yeah well I have
some new stuff in there every once in a
while sure but it's about the greatest
hits whereas versus somebody like Louie
is like no no no you'll never hear me
say those old stuff I play new things
every time you see me it's a new it's
the new hour kind of thing and it's like
but don't get it twisted Jerry's still
working on new material
you know what I mean like it's not like
he's just never gonna perform the new
material it's just that he just has a
different philosophy about how he
performs it and some people and there's
some comedians that uh uh only play The
Greatest Hits and people go watch them
over and over and over and over again
because of the greatest hits
yep yep you know what I mean so I think
we are I don't know if you know I don't
know too many comedians not like Jerry
Seinfeld who are Greatest Hits comedian
and only play The Greatest Hits I feel
like just maybe this newer generation
now I sound old this new generation of
people yeah I mean it's all new material
crowd work clip how can I go
all right
I have my notes on stage
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was Andrew Schultz and someone dang
it talking about how Clips have ruined
comedy this was Andrew Schultz that said
this the guy who started Clips comedy I
can't gosh I can't remember what that
was from but it was funny to hear them
talking about it as like old heads like
man eclipse or everything now
yeah yeah yeah I mean but it's it's just
I think sadly we've we've all Fallen
victim to
what's working and what's getting us
more eyeballs and at the moment Clips is
getting more eyeballs you know I'm
saying so like stand-up clubs and not
just regular stand-up clips clips with
crowd work is getting more eyeballs and
that's crowd work is interesting yeah
that's just the algorithm you know what
I'm saying so at the moment the
algorithm is kind of dictating all the
stuff that you're kind of seeing right
now but that's because people are
recognizing hey this is how I'm getting
as many eyes on my material as possible
if you get you know forty thousand uh
views on a crowd work clip well your
hope is that that translates into new
fans
you know what I mean so yeah but it's
tough man because then it's like you're
a new comic you go viral now you're
selling tickets people expect you to do
an hour off a crowd work clip and you
have an open mic seven which really is
probably three
on a good day you know I'm just saying
I'm not saying don't post Clips do
whatever you want to do I'm just saying
there's that side of the game as well of
like yeah you know what do you want to
be out there forever what like
what do you what do you want to be known
for but I mean at the end of the day you
know it's kind of your personal
preference I don't want to say get funny
and all this will take care of itself
um so that's what Barry Katz said on the
podcast be undeniable it's like okay
yeah check okay cool be undeniable I'll
I'll we'll work on that yeah yeah but
then that's what Nate bargatzi says and
it took him 20 20 years and now he just
sold out Bridgestone Arena so
there is something to just like hey just
get good and people will find you type
deal
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean it is
I think top of the scale
number one thing is to
get funny
and figure out that has not changed now
the mechanics of how you put your
material out and how you go viral and
how you get more people that you know
that that's changing damn near every
every week like what uh what platform do
I put it on all this other stuff
but what hasn't changed is you do have
to just have material and people have to
resonate with it you do have to be funny
and I think I think it might have been
the Barry cats one about
that's table Stakes
funniest table Stakes
funny is the minimum
you know what I mean yeah so if you're
not even good at that like the other
stuff just isn't going to come
um but I mean I'll say there's there's
comedians even like in the hot breath
Network that have found
viralness in different ways
and have stepped up and become even
funny because the they've showed up when
the time showed like they started
booking next thing you know you're like
oh I'm booking shows
I gotta get funny you know I mean not
not that they weren't funny before but
like to a certain point so I think it's
just a good yeah it's just a good lesson
man being funny and the work and the set
and the material that never changes
yeah and Jerry asked about your World
Series set but let's get there's a few
questions before that I just want to
tease it for people watching we're gonna
get to the we're gonna get to what
happened this
this weekend I'm so excited
um but uh Jack Allen asked do you think
tags on jokes have to get as good a
response as the initial Punch or better
to justify keeping them if it gets
laughs but not as strong elaps as the
punch do you drop it
well there's a basic there's a basic
like
structure of a bit that it's like you
need to end on the best laugh so like a
joke should like crescendo
into I mean Applause would be ideal but
there is a progression to a joke you
don't want to have a big punch and then
a bunch of tags that just kind of Fade
Out type deal you want like each thing I
think was it uh the joke doctor calls
them Toppers I think it's a common
industry term but it's like you want to
top so you want your tag to actually add
to the joke and build on the laughs and
not like take away from it yeah and the
thing about tags and Toppers I do like
joke doctors uh reference the name of it
the thing about Toppers is that because
from a psychological perspective because
people are already laughing
it's easier for them to laugh at the
next thing
right it's easier for them to laugh at
the tag you're kind of getting them into
a rhythm of your same Rhythm so your the
next tag it's not necessarily should be
funnier but should have a better
reference to the punch line than maybe
the joke itself but it should definitely
Crescendo your laughter to where you're
like
yeah and like you said like where you're
getting like an Applause break that's
definitely the key to I say all tags I
mean and I think I told you this uh
George Wallace mentioned six tags that
was his rule he said six tags on
everything and you're not that you need
them all but just have them and he said
he would work out which one would work
and I saw him do two shows and I saw him
do two tags on One show and I saw him
did five tags on another and when he did
those five tags the crowd was in
stitches there were just they lost it
they were because it was just bam bam
bam it was just like this Crescendo and
yeah did he get a pause break at the end
of it abso freaking lutely because he
was just killing him with the tags and
he said you just got to know when to
pull it out versus when like not do it
and I think when he did the first time
he realized that it wasn't that big of a
laugh so he just did two tags it still
worked but the second Show when he did
the five tags
you could just see like the room just
like lit up from those five tags
um
Bobby Bobby had a question
um what's the best way to tell a venue
owner that they need to move their stage
without offending them it's just a mic
and carpet
no disassembly required PS
cuz make venue owners don't want advice
from women how do I get heard because
it's hurting everybody in the show
oh Minnie oh she called me many than you
owners don't worry uh oh yeah I'd
probably say
maybe come at it as a collective rather
than come at it as an individual
maybe like go up to the venue owner
together with other comedians even in a
group and say hey
um we would just find it more reasonable
if we were to move the stage here what
do you think about that I mean you can
have a leader but like if you go as a
gang I think it may be a little easier
and that's just me sort of just thinking
off the top that
as working with other venues especially
at an open mic they tend to respond
because they know that you know the the
comics are part of the clientele because
if they don't have the comics they won't
have literally anyone there right as a
group that might work a little better
but you know venue owners are a
different kind of personality so try
that if that doesn't work then maybe you
know I also say hit up the people at the
bar or tell the bartenders or tell
people that work there
and get them to sort of
give them the information so it's kind
of like the telephone game use somebody
that you know that they'll listen to
mostly and I think that would work
yeah and probably the number one thing
when it comes to producing a show is
picking the right venue and making sure
that it's a venue that
it the venue should care about the show
as much as you do like it should be a
collaborative effort there should be
conversations around
okay this show did this what can we do
for the next one that'll make it better
or how do we Market this one and how can
we do better on this next one or maybe
we should move it around a little bit
and like
the best shows are the ones that are
collaborative with in the venue and the
venue is is invested in the show as you
are that's from personal experience and
from interviewing so many show Bookers
but if you approach this venue owner
Bobby not from a place of
you're doing this wrong let me tell you
how to do it but like based on your
experience as a comedian I have seen
other shows set up like this way to
actually do better what do you think
about trying moving the stage over here
or whatnot like not coming from a
combative place but like I enjoy working
together I've seen other shows have
success with this what do you say we
give it a shot and make this show
hopefully a bigger success you know
coming from a place of empathy and like
just you know you're not telling the
restaurant owner how to sell chicken
tenders you know but you're there as a
comedian like oh let's see how we can
serve comedy the best way possible yeah
I like that yeah that's a good approach
I think it's about empathy is the good
is a good word there like how and here's
the thing restaurant owners like it's
not like
most most of them aren't going to be
like oh that's a terrible idea I mean I
have a hard time believing they will be
like they would say that unless they
just have something stuck up their wooha
or something but I I would say most
people would listen especially with an
open mic
and they're trying to get more people
into the place or trying to get you know
just a better show overall
oh great I guess Bobby's talking about
the show we're doing we're doing a show
and Villa Rica together at a brewery and
she's like oh great we can collectively
talk to them at this point
that's called a setup that's called the
open set up can you see how this show
goes
The okey-doke Oblong Services says
Shalom was goody fam salad cream boy hey
Tocco Carlson say something funny
laughs
he just called me Taco Carlson dude at
difference
like I look like different people at
different hair links like whenever I
have shorter hair I get called certain
things and ever longer hair I get called
certain things I can't escape that all
white people look the same
for sure especially your facial features
if you have a generic brand of what
there's a generic brand of white that
just fits your brand you know what I
mean facts
yeah for sure there's like four types of
what you're definitely probably one
through three you know I can check some
boxes there yeah
not other I I could check everything but
other there's no other here that's for
sure I am no other right yeah
original
[Laughter]
OG around here
that's hilarious uh Dan Conroy asked I
think this was in relation to us talking
about open mic's first real audiences
how do we find a real audience
oh
it's a legit question
it's a very legit question
I mean for a while it may just be open
mics like and like especially if you're
in like a smaller town maybe or in a
scene where you're not quote in yet it
may be a bunch of open mics that maybe
comedy open mics Music open mics Pro
Tropa mics I've performed on karaoke
nights like I've I've done it all coming
up you know so if you're not really
getting booked or whatnot but you want
to you can be more proactive about going
to book shows introducing yourself to
the booker and being like I'm a comedian
and I love what you're doing if you ever
have any spots I'd greatly appreciate it
or
hey I'm a local comedian here what is
the best way to get to contact you with
my tape about maybe doing this show
sometime or approaching it that way or
doing your own show is another route as
well where you start producing your own
show and start building an audience that
way there's a there's a few ways to kind
of get the juices flowing
yeah yeah I mean
yeah I mean I think real audience comes
from marketing and that is a two-way
street where you as a producer has to
Market and then the venue also has to do
some level of marketing if they're
trying to get a real audience email
lists work if you can try to find a way
to get emails from people at the show
most people that have come especially to
like a brewery show or like a small show
usually come because they're already
regular visitors of the venue so also
say it's really good to just advertise
at the venue that there might be like a
showcase show coming or there might be a
um you know something happening you know
every first Friday or every second
Saturday whenever your show's happening
try to work the actual Club itself or
the venue itself because
if they're regular is there then they're
probably down to be like oh there's
going to be comedy here this weekend let
me check my schedule and see what
happens so yeah I think that's a good
idea
exactly yeah there's yeah there's
um
a few a few things to look for in a
venue is like do they have do they
already have kind of a local following
or are they actively promoting what
they're already doing are they already
doing Live Events are they doing music
are they doing bingo are they doing
karaoke like are they already kind of
doing live events that comedy would just
kind of fit into their overall kind of
marketing plan in general and not trying
to build a venue from the ground up but
kind of meet a venue where they are that
is just as jazzed about the event as you
are I cannot stress that enough making
sure that like the venue cares as much
about the show as you do because running
a show was already a lot of work and if
it's the venue's not helping out at all
it's gonna make it miserable and you do
comedy because it's fun
and that will ruin all the fun
immediately
it's the anti-fun yeah for sure and it
takes time you know if you want to start
a show
you kind of plant the seed in your mind
and now everywhere you go you can kind
of start to stake out like oh would this
be a good venue or that maybe you know
let me walk around town a little bit and
see like or I'm at this restaurant oh I
wonder if we could set up over there you
just start looking for it and you'll
find it but
it's better to take the time to find the
right venue than try to rush into it
because oh I want to start my own show
now it's like well give it some time you
can find the right venue and you'll do
that show for years instead of just like
a month or two and then you end up
resenting the entire place you know so
because running a show isn't no joke
like I think it was
Kyle the guy who owns don't tell comedy
he said on the podcast that it's like
his advice to anyone wants to produce a
show is to don't do stand-up comedy
because you can't do both successfully
like it's just so much work to produce
your own show
um
that's why co-producing can be so
valuable like Yoshi and I will do
because it's if you can co-produce and
find at least one other person to do it
with you that'll save a lot as well
for sure yeah yeah I mean and there's I
know a lot of good code producers like
Holly and Amber in town yeah go produce
and killing it but I think that's just a
it's a good way like to know your
strengths versus like what you prefer
not to do right and so I think just
however you can make the work less and
then just use your strength to make the
show all that it can be but it's so
important for the venues to actually be
invested in the success of the show as
well that is very important
kind bud dank nug said is this live it
feels like a replay well with a name
like that I'm not surprised that it
feels like a replay
I'm sure your memory is not the best
there's such a that is such a dank but
is this live bro is this is this live
right now what yo this is trippy yo this
is this feels like a replay
there's no way Tucker Carlson's given
comedy advice now what is happening
Steve said I look like Brett from the
animated show inside job
I don't know what that is
there's so many references it's just
like whatever generic white dude
let me see
I'm gonna google this guy and see what's
his name are you Brett are you gonna
google generic white dude hilarious
[Laughter]
okay so here's Brett
sorry for the podcast listeners you can
watch us on YouTube
oh my God I did just Google generic
white guy and three of these people look
like you for sure
oh let me see
oh I can't can I not pull it up here
can I not pull up the screen share for
people to see
oh well that's all right you don't want
to see you guys don't want to see it
anyway
yeah you guys don't
guess but the live stream like Joe what
are you doing right now
I think I can I think I can I think I
can
I think I can I think I can
um okay we're one step closer here
laughs
all right never mind if you Google Brett
from inside job
it's a cartoon I look like a cartoon
I've heard Fix It Felix before
this is great
how interesting
it's fine don't worry about it everyone
oh my God that is so true
hahaha what did I look like him oh there
it is
[Laughter]
there it is they can see it live now
okay yes
that is very funny
that is totally what that was totally
worth pulling up
that was totally worth pulling up that
is so I don't know what show this is
[Laughter]
yo all I'm saying is book your boy all
right if you need a generic white guy
holla I'm the plug
Mo all of my acting experience has
basically been as the generic white guy
so I'll let your boy
that's so funny
that is hilarious
cartoon Brett from inside job well thank
you Steve I really appreciate that that
means a lot coming from Steve who also
looks like a generic white guy so I
guess real recognize real
um
oh
I was looking at the actor who is Brett
and
he's very different than you oh like the
voice actor
yeah
yeah I've never even heard of this show
oh oh and um oh Jeff Cohn said late to
the game way to crush it at McCurdy's
last week Yoshi okay let's
we're almost there let's let's run
through a few more questions
what do you say
yeah let's do it do we need a timer do
we need a timer because we will run
um
so we got Bobby's we got Dan's
I know Oz had one let me make sure there
wasn't one before that uh
uh the the the the
all right let's let's run through a few
here so Carol Freeman tips for getting
an audience back or resetting if all
your normal jokes that get laughs aren't
working
oh that's a good question
um I saw
uh Chris Set It Off Jones I saw him at
Star Bar one time and it was killing the
crowd killing the crowd and then he ran
into a joke that just just did not do
well
and what he did afterwards I thought was
just absolutely magical
because what he did is he he basically
said I love that you guys came out here
and collectively decided that
I was not worth the laughs and what it
did is that it made the audience become
the butt of the joke but collectively
they all agreed on the exact same thing
which is he was not funny
and I thought that was such a good like
just something in the chamber just have
something to prepare for when those
times happen to them reset the room I
think is just a good tool in the toolkit
yeah I had a joke that was like oh that
joke killed in front of my Furbies
um something I would say so you can have
these Savor lines but also something
that uh Chris did there is he kind of
like addressed the elephant in the room
so he was like oh I love how we all
agreed not to laugh at that now yeah I
had a I had a joke I had a set I'll
never forget
at uh Uptown where I was killing and all
of a sudden stopped like I just
everything just started dying and then
I like I stopped the set and I literally
like leaned into the audience and I was
like where did I lose you I was like
where did we go wrong here
like was it this joke was it because I
said this or that like and I was like
reversing the set like where did I lose
y'all and I really like got real in the
moment
and just like had a conversation with
the audience about what happened how do
we get here how can we move on from here
and I actually was able to recover now
not necessarily you'll recover every
time from that but it's a way to
actually create an authentic connection
with the audience and actually have an
authentic moment that may or may not
need to laughter but it makes you
stronger and more confident on stage
because you're actually kind of breaking
through your script and like okay what's
Happening Here what are we doing in this
moment and it's real and authentic and
that's what the audience appreciates and
it makes you present that you just you
didn't realize like because you don't
want to sound too robotic on stage so I
think right just a good lesson to at
least make sure you address it but if
you can address it with a joke whether
it's canned whether it's in the moment
it's always helpful and it's a good way
to let the audience in on knowing that
yeah we all recognize what's going on
here
mm-hmm yeah so I hope that helps there
Carol but it's
yeah it's it's a process like but I
think starting there and addressing the
elephant in the room will will help
tremendously of like just you being more
confident when those moments happen
um because a lot of time when we're like
oh the audience hates me they're just
they're just they're there they're just
waiting on the next joke they're not
thinking oh that tag didn't work that we
hate this person they don't know a joke
doesn't work unless you tell them at the
end of the day so yeah
um take that take that with perspective
as well because sometimes
the set is just you keep going and you
eventually win them over but
I mean it's tough Yoshi because a lot of
this is you just gotta be on stage a lot
like yeah yeah yeah it's like at a
certain point it's like you just have to
fail so many times that you understand
oh I've been in this moment before
here's how I can recover from it because
50 other times before this I cried and
hated myself for a month like
of knowing that you've seen and you've
played this not even played it but it's
happened to you before right uh I always
tell people if you have a bomb if you
have a bomb set do whatever you can
to do an another set
quickly after that bomb set as possible
so you don't have the taste of the bomb
just sitting there with you for too long
you just gotta
get over it but the best way to get over
it another set best way to get over that
another set and it's just get those reps
in
and that that's a big part of why like
the culture of hot breath is just Comics
helping comics and being very positive
and supportive because yes we do have
classes and workshops but if you don't
apply what you learn onto the stage like
the the really learning the craft of
Comedy as being on stage a lot it's
doing these open mics at 1am on a
Tuesday when you have to be up for work
at seven it's like so if you can have a
supportive Community around you
throughout this grind that is comedy
then it's going to make it a lot more
fun and you're going to develop a lot
faster
but there's really no way around the
work
no way
sorry
no way around the work there's really
not uh but these tips are here to help
but you just have to like take them and
like apply them basically sure
um
uh Oz how do you cope with the bitter
Petty people
in the business that think everyone is
out to get them
is it just me or does anyone else run
into these people
were literally like hot breath is
positive and supportive and you're like
what about the people that aren't
[Laughter]
uh I mean honestly just just know that
those people will exist
but those people don't determine your
future they don't determine your past
they don't determine anything about you
they're just there uh I think this is
one of those cases where only control
the things you can control and the
things that are within purview
everything else you know is it the
Serenity the serenity Clause uh or the
Serenity Prayer
uh we're going to AAA here is that yeah
is it like
um I know you're talking about though
God grant me
the ability to read this
God grant me the serenity to accept the
things I cannot change courage to change
the things I can and wisdom to know the
difference yeah
yeah
that's the key right there is just
you're not going to be able to control
so many of those Petty people those
people are Petty because they've gone
through some stuff and they might have a
reason to be Petty but it's not your
issue to figure out
um I think the big thing for you is just
told things that you can which is
getting good at comedy being nice to
people networking uh really the stuff
that you can actually have a positive
impact from which is I can get good at
my material I can go network with people
ask people questions I can get tips I
can do all the work part of this and
yeah there might be just an a-hole at
the club who's just like man you're not
funny but he's not going to affect
everything that you you are doing he's
just one person so yeah try to if
possible stay clear of those people you
don't have to always be around them
be nice be funny focus on what you can
control exactly and be yeah that's why
hot breadth is so positive supportive
because I came up
and there were a lot of these types of
people so hopefully the goal is people
hear this show and start to kind of
infiltrate their own local scenes with
that positive supportive vibe that we're
all in this together and comedy is hard
enough as it is so being mean to other
comedians only hurt yourself as well but
you're not going to change people just
focus on what you can control
which is being nice and getting funny
big fakes
big yes
well let's get to your
um
I mean let's get to your weekend what do
you think Yoshi I mean this is a big
this is a big deal
this is a big deal I mean tell tell I
don't want to overplay it here you know
but I mean tell the people what happened
what's going on with you you were down
in Florida this past weekend making
moves what what what's popping here
yeah so I was at the World Series and
I'm in the uh sword series they pretty
much bring like 40 Comics uh to every
location and there's like different
rounds within those uh
within the shows and I was on the
Thursday show and a Thursday show is
like the first round of the second
it's the second round the first of the
second round and two Comics go from each
of the second rounds
the final
and so I placed first in this in the the
Thursday show and uh it was a good it
was a good show
um I think like you know after the shows
I'm always like in my head about this
stuff but I would say the biggest lesson
for me is just like just consistency and
like just really work out the material
that uh that you think is a showcase
there's definitely an element within the
World Series and I think any time you're
doing like a showcase or like you're
performing for Bookers where they want
your best stuff
and when you're performing your best
stuff it's just good to make sure that
it's like Top Notch your best stuff
so for me you know this is material that
I've had over the eight years I've been
doing comedy some of it comes from like
year one some of it comes from like
three months ago but it's like my best
stuff and so I think it's always
important that you are just displaying
and showing your best whenever you're in
front of Bookers or you're doing
contests and you know contest and comedy
is just kind of a weird thing but at the
same time
it's it's just a part of the process
sometimes of just doing what you know to
be oh this is like it's like the
highlights reel like a basketball player
can't just do a highlights reel and show
you his best stuff like while watching
just do it you might have to put it all
together so I think this is what really
the World Series in any really contest
is about is put all your good stuff
together
and then perform it and so
did I mean I would say one of the
biggest lesson for me last like couple
years is I've figured out how to move my
best material into like different orders
to make sure that the when I'm leaving
the audience I'm leaving with like the
biggest
laugh right and so so that's I mean
I probably didn't learn that till like
two years ago
like it's my best stuff used to be like
in the middle and then
I'd you know what I thought was the best
I'd leave to the end but I literally
went back and watched like 10 tapes
and literally check the decibel levels
of what laughter was the biggest and it
was always one joke and I was like why
am I not putting this at the end and
then I just started putting it at the
end especially in a five minute material
but like part of it is like my material
sort of is chronological where I tell
you
a little bit about my past a little bit
about my present and sort of just so
it's got a Chrono chronology to it but
the joke itself didn't live on its own
so after I started moving it to where it
was living on its own then I got the
biggest laughs at the end so but yeah uh
it was a good set that room is just
rocking it was 300 people and for all
like six shows
it was nuts dude yeah I've heard
McCurdy's killer in Sarasota is one of
the best clubs in the country just yeah
that's an OG Club they've been around
since the old days yeah just good good
people good crowd like I mean definitely
old people but man
they love comedy they love comedy there
I mean here's the thing these the two
shows that we had uh or the one shows
like it starts like at six or seven like
they're an early crowd they get to bed
they got to get to bed by like 8 30.
amen
amen I'm not messing around
oh dude I'm doing three o'clock shows
I'm telling you what dude I'm
that's what that that's when you all
know your boy is on I'm doing three
o'clock shows yeah yeah
just good show and then I got it it
happened all again this week There's an
Atlanta World Series and yeah are you
going yeah yeah I'll be there I'll be
there too I don't know if anyone
watching right now or listen to the
podcast is going to be there but um
let's connect we always meet hot
breathers at these uh especially a World
Series dude we deep out there yeah yeah
what I mean you're you're playing it
very cool
I mean you've been doing World Series
for a while and you you hit it I mean
you won this round so like did you like
was it just moving the joke to the end
or did something different like what I
don't know you've just been kind of
working towards this for a while of like
this goal of you wanna you wanna win
around and then go on and hopefully win
the festival so like yeah you do
something different what are you feeling
what have you learned like you're being
very like cool
I think the biggest thing is just
not to get in my head about
does that make sense like it's just
trust the material more than anything
and here's the thing like what's great
about the World Series is man the notes
that they give you are just spectacular
right and yeah they're awesome in the
World Series gives you like just deep
notes and the notes that I got was very
much the same that I felt on stage so
knowing that that's where it was I think
for me it was like okay then I'm doing
the right thing I think the biggest
thing that I've recognized from the show
in doing the World Series and so I
didn't win
Sarasota like I didn't win the entire
Sarasota but I won my round and then the
top six
like I did well but man the competition
was deep dude I didn't move on to the
top three
but I didn't feel bad about my set I was
very happy with my set it was just fire
comedians on the show that I was
it was just like I mean could I have
done better sure but at the same time I
was happy with what I did because I went
in and performed the best stuff that I
could because I've done some different
sure but there was not any like
I gave them the business is the best one
could describe it that's great yeah and
that shows just like comedians were just
funny dude like it was just that night
just was like I mean like if you watch
that night of Comedy you would have been
like oh my God like everybody was in
Stick
and everybody destroyed that crowd so it
was just like one of those things you're
like all right this is just what it is
and that's the good thing about the
World Series sometimes I can never tell
you who I think won because there'll be
like five or six people that just
murdered the crowd and he was like I
don't know what the jokes are gonna do
it's like they were all killer yeah
and so I mean I think a lot of that
happened at McCurdy's because there were
some Heavy Hitters at McCurdy's uh this
weekend
yeah that's what I mean you know we've
had the CEO of World Series on several
times and like the most recent one I
think he was like if you're if you're
submitting to this Festival to win it's
like then don't bother it's like it's
really hard to win like it's great for
networking and getting quality stage
time and getting that feedback and
meeting other great Comics but it's it's
hard to win that's why I was so jazzed
for even you winning you're saying you
didn't win the whole thing but like you
won a round because I it's you know
you've you've been hammering away at
this you know what I mean so to see your
picture in the email I was like yeah I
think I think for me like just
like
at first the goal was okay I want to win
a couple of like you know because when
you're starting out you're not winning
all of them right and like your tape
kind of moves you into certain places
within the World Series
I just wanted to win and perform the
best right and so I felt good about like
my performance and I think what it is
like I just like really got it down to
like okay
in from a showcase set
how do I get the most laughs in this set
and working on that and sort of just
like hitting those things like really
like I would say is what helped me get
to where I was this weekend is like
just perform the show like do the thing
that you do best and just like hit it
um and so I think that's that's the big
thing for me is I am not worried about
winning the contest I just want to kill
on every single stage that I'm on that's
the key for me that's and I'd obviously
that's only been in the last like two
years dude like I think the first couple
years I was in the World Series it's
like I'm trying to win I'm trying to win
I'm trying to win and then I recognize
that that just was not fruitful at all
you like squeeze it you end up
suffocating it and it takes the fun out
of it too and it's the fun out of it and
that's the other thing I think is super
important man usually you just gotta
have fun like at the end of the day
performing in front of people right and
I think when I go in like oh I'm just
performing my hot five minutes less go
like that shift for me always does well
um and the audience feels it the judges
feel it I mean there's been times where
I felt like I've performed and I felt
very robotic of just saying the jokes
versus like performing versus like
actually being in it and I think that's
important to actually be in it
amen yeah and Jeff Cohn said he's gonna
be at the punchline show on Friday the
late one at 10. very nice and Jeff
murdered by the way if you guys don't
know a dude murder at this stage yeah I
watched the show it was amazing
that's exciting yeah we'll have to
connect I'll definitely have an early
show on Friday but I should be able to
pull up to the late one
um yeah what what
oh I don't want to say the comedian's
name but there was a community at the
punchline this past weekend
I don't y'all can go on the calendar and
look who I don't want to say anything
negative I respect his business and what
he's done
but it was not great and he did 35
minutes
and it was
because I never want to disparage anyone
that gets on that stage like you
standing on that stage is more than most
people would ever do in their life the
fact you're up there means you're
conquering a fear that the majority of
the world has
but like I went to see what it was all
about and I was just like all right wow
wow 35 minutes
but anyway I don't want to end on a
negative note it just made me think of
that when you're talking about the punch
line so they did 35 minutes and it was
boo-boo is that what you're saying
yeah yeah and I was asked I asked the
club beforehand like how how because I
know he has a reputation and I was just
like oh how how's he doing how the
show's been going and all this and it
was all positive and I was like oh cool
and then like 20 minutes in I'm like
stressing a cookie from the diner like I
can't handle this right now
this is rough I I relapsed on sugar
that's how bad it was
um oh
yeah I know I know exactly I know
exactly who it is that you're talking
about
but I I respect his hustle and I really
want to see his stand up and like to see
what it was about and it really
it really was what Reddit says and I
really hated that but um
it's all positive I respect anyone that
gets on that stage so
I don't end on a negative note I don't
end on a negative note I I respect all
Comics
um for sure actually you got shows
coming up this week what you got this
week
yes well I'll be at the world series
shows at the punch line and
that's is that Wednesday and Thursday
Friday Saturday yeah
Wednesday Thursday Friday and Saturday
yeah and then um I have a show in
I'm in Atlanta on Friday I have a show
it just says on the calendar Kenny
Atlanta show so I'll have to look at the
details on what that one is
um it'll be at the punchline Friday this
late show and then Bobby and I are doing
uh with Joyce Lyles another hot breather
tamagram another hot breather we're
doing in Villa Rica we're performing
at uh hixton brewing in Villa Rica so
that's exciting and um before that I'll
be doing a fundraiser show
nice that I'm very excited about as well
here here in Atlanta see I'm in Atlanta
this weekend and then like next weekend
um you and I are doing a um a country
club
I'll actually be going to Austin for a
few days next weekend
and early May I'll be up in like the
Virginia area for peeps that wanna
holla
nice that's awesome
yeah I have uh I've got uh I'll be on
the punchline show Thursday which is the
19th let's go it's like 20 the 20th I'll
be on the 20th but the World Series
please come out to the World Series if
you can it's on Wednesday Thursday
Friday and Saturday yeah for sure
Thursday show Thursday show is at eight
um
and then uh and hopefully I'll be able
to get on the Saturday shows uh but if
that I literally have a show on Saturday
if I don't make it uh in Roswell and
then also have a show Friday night with
uh some local comedians as well which I
think is also a fundraiser so I think
it's a private event
with another comic so yeah and that's
like we're working we bookable you know
we open to be booked y'all so holla at
us let's work
I I think that's like one of the other
lesson
um probably recently not recently but
like just know that it doesn't always
have to be a comedy club that you're
working at like comedy clubs don't have
the choke hold on Comedy there's so many
different places you can perform comedy
I think uh Dave uh schwenson last week
mentioned that it was just like you know
there's so many different venues like so
many different you know Toastmasters and
different places and fundraisers that
you can just go do comedy and they're
looking for comedians especially clean
comedians who are willing to work and so
just know that you don't have to be
subjugated to just the comedy club
atmosphere to do comedy
they're not the only ones doing comedy
though
exactly amen yeah a lot of talk about
producing your own shows this week so
hopefully maybe that'll Inspire some
people to
give it a go
create their own opportunities
but that is it for this week man we do
this live stream every Tuesday at 5 PM
eastern time
and Steve asked if it was TI that I saw
it was not T.I it was not yeah it was
like a comedian I mean he has like a
podcast he has several podcasts he's
very successful
I was just thinking a punchline and I
was like I want to say it out loud
because I was I was rooting for him I
really was
yeah
but and it's so it's okay to say that it
was not what you expected and then at
night it could have been an off show as
well like listen absolutely we all have
off shows the fact even brought it up I
hope I didn't just manifest one of those
for myself just based on Karma listen
everyone has awesome nights
so you know just just make sure
[Laughter]
I'm going through the world seriously oh
this is what Joel's about oh
no I love I love you all and I love
comedy and I love doing this and I love
you all for listening and sharing the
show and hopefully we'll see y'all next
week during the live stream for sure
yeah it was a good good week man
let's get it
amen well go forth hot breathiverse
as Bobby said in the comments yes what's
goody wait
angels angels on y'all y'all have a good
week Hopper at the verse we'll see y'all
next week